I hope everyone had a nice break and
welcome back to the end of the world.
So, as you know, World War II has
started. United States and Israel have
start to attack Iran
and we are now in the fourth day of this
war. And we can expect this war to last
for many weeks, possibly also for many
years. But I promise you that after this
war is done, the world will never be the
same again. So what what we will do
these next few weeks is use game theory
and understand and analyze the
geopolitical situation.
And so I'm going to teach you the ideas,
the theories, the techniques to
understand the world around you and make
predictions. and we can know if our
analysis is correct because all this is
happening in real time and so we can
test it against reality. All right, so
let's go over some basic facts about
what's happened so far. So in the early
morning of Saturday uh in Tran the
Israelis and Americans launched a
decapitation strike against the Alatona
uh Hami who is the supreme leader of
Iran. Now there are
arguments and and disputes about as to
what happened. The Americans and
Israelis said that they had real
intelligence about where the leader was
and so they sent airplanes to just bomb
the crap out of a place. They also had a
spy who was able to record the body of
the dead to
this was announced. At first, the
Iranians denied this and the Iranians
insisted he was still alive. But
eventually, state media um admitted that
he did die in the air strike. But then
what they also said is that they had
told he's 86 years old and he chose to
die. He could have gone to Moscow, but
instead he chose to stay in Tran and die
for his people. But not only that, but
he died along many of his relatives. He
died along with his daughter, his
son-in-law, his grandchildren. So the
entire So many of the family died in
this assault.
Also, there's been reporting that he had
prostrate cancer. Okay? So he was going
to die fairly soon as well. So what you
need to understand first about the war
is that even though the Americans and
the Israelis claim great success in
decapitating the leadership of the
Iranians from the Iranian perspective
this is a martyrdom martyrdom. Okay.
And so the religion of the Iranians is
called Shia
um Muslim. And this is different from
Sunni
Muslim. So uh Sunnis are the majority.
They're about 9% of all Muslims in the
world. The Shia have always been the
minority. And as such, they've always
been persecuted. So in the Shia faith,
the core value, the force that binds
everyone together and gives them purpose
and meaning in life, that galvanizes
them into action is the idea of
martyrdom, which forces jihad. to
sacrifice yourself for your religion.
Sacrifice yourself for the common good.
So think of the death of Kam as a
sacrifice, a self-sacrifice in order to
motivate their radiance in this war.
Okay? So that's the first thing you need
to understand that for the Iranians,
this is not a biblical war. This is not
an economic war. This is not a war of
resistance. This is a jihad. Okay?
Right? It's a war against the great
Satan to avenge their leader. They will
fight to the death. All right? That's
number one. Number two is this.
Also, that morning when um the was
killed, they really struck a school in
the south of Tran killing about 150
school children. These are girls in
primary school. And again, there's not
debate and argument as to what happened.
This really said that first of all, the
school was next to a military base. We
are targeting military base. And second
of all, it wasn't us which struck the
school. It was a air defense missile
that went off course. Okay. And the
Iranians insisted no. The the Israelis
purposefully attacked the school to kill
the school children. And then you're
like, why would the Israelis do that?
But then these few years, well, we've
seen what they've done in Gaza, in
Palestine to the Palestinians, and it's
pretty consistent what the Israelis have
been doing. All right? So this action
against the Israelis, it's meant to show
to themselves in the world that we are
now allin. Okay? We've made the
sacrifice. We are now committed to this
war to win this war at all costs and
this action has also provoked the
Iranian people to resist with their full
might. Okay. So I want you to keep this
in mind and again we don't have complete
evidence that it's the Israelis who did
this but given past actions from the
Israelis this is fairly consistent with
what they've done. Okay. So we can
assume that this is something that do
did why they did this what the purpose
is something we we will discuss as we
move on okay it's very complicated
next I want to show you this this is
Dubai and Dubai is considered one of the
wealthiest safest cities in the world
there are thousands tens of thousands of
westerners who move to Dubai because
it's clean you don't pay any taxes you
make a lot of money and you there are
great restaurants and this is really the
economic model of Dubai. It's one of the
Gulf the GCC countries, okay? The Gulf
uh coastal countries. And for the
longest time, Dubai had a really good
deal because they were under the
protection of the American military. So
they didn't have to pay for defense.
They and then they were in the Middle
East, which is the oil producing um
center of the world. And so they focus
on aviation, they focus on logistics,
they focus on finance, on tourism. They
be extremely wealthy, right? I'm not
sure if you've taken Emirates, one of
the best airlines in the world. So their
airport, Dubai airport, is the busiest
in the world. And Dubai for the longest
time was flourishing under American
protection. And Dubai said to the world,
listen, we're like Switzerland. We're
neutral. We don't want any involvement
in any wars. we're here just to take
care of our citizens, to make sure every
has a good time to make money. And then
right after the war started, the
Iranians attacked
the uh GCC. Okay, Dubai, Abu Dhabi,
uh Ban, Qatar,
Kuwait, they attacked these places and
these places were like, "What's going
on? We're neutral, man. We're not
involved in this war." and the airport
was shut down in Dubai. At at one point,
rich the rich people in Dubai were
willing to pay about 250,000 US dollars
just get on a plane and get out of
there. Okay.
So, um the reality is this. For the
longest time, Dubai had a reputation for
being safe and that's why people move
their money there. Guess what, guys?
After what the Iranians did, it's dead.
Dubai as a city in the long term it is
dead because you're a wealthy westerner.
You're not going to move to a place
where it could be attacked any time by
the Iranians. You might move to
Singapore. You might move to Hong Kong,
Japan, South America, but you're not
moving to Dubai. Okay. So, the big
question for us is why do I do this? It
would say it's really Americans who
attack you. Why go after the GCC? All
right. and not only that, but they're
escalating the attacks against the GCC.
So, it's something that we will look at
very closely today. Well, the short
answer is because these places, even
though they they pretend to be neutral,
they house the American military. They
allow the Israelis and Americans to use
their airspace to attack Iran from. All
right. So, this is Bahrain. Now, Bane is
interesting, okay? Because I I want you
guys to remember this, but Bane will
probably be one of the major centers of
this conflict because first of all, this
is the um American fifth fleet. All
right, this is their naval base in the
Middle East. And as you can see, the
Iranians are attacking it with missiles
and it's being blown up. Bin is
interesting because it has about 50% or
even more. Okay. Shia, which is the
religion of the Iranians, but the people
in charge are the Sunnis.
And so what is the what makes this
strike really important for from our
perspective is first of all, not only
are the Iranians attacking US military
assets, not only are they destroying the
economies of the GCC, but they're also
also trying to ignite a religious war,
right? If you're Shia, you're loyal to
the Aatollah. And if he's dead, then you
must as a religious obligation now
commit jihad against your enemies. And
it's no different in other religions
where listen, if you want to kill the
Pope, the Catholics would be really
angry at you and they would want to kill
you, right? So now you have the Shia who
will probably eventually arise creating
a revolution
in Ban. Okay? Okay. So I think Boran
will be the first to fall. Dubai will
probably go bankrupt. Okay. But in the
long term we can expect the entire GCC
area including Saudi Arabia
to eventually collapse. Okay. And this
something we will use game theory to
understand. All right let's continue. So
we will know how this war develops just
based on geography. Okay. So this is a
map and this map even even if you don't
really know the war, even if you don't
know the participants, even if you don't
know the weaponry, this map will tell
you exactly how this war will progress.
All right, so some certain things to
keep in mind about this map. This is
what we call this area. Okay, really
small about it's 33 kilometers wide.
Okay, people can swim across it. It's
really really um uh narrow. Okay, this
small area guys, it's called the str
moose.
All right,
and it's important because
it's really the center of the world.
This one area is the nexus, the pivot of
the world. Let me explain why. First of
all, from the GCC, you have 20%
of all the world's oil flowing through
this narrow straight. Where does it go,
guys? It goes to Asia, India, Pakistan,
South Korea, China, Japan.
India depends on 60% of its oil from
this area. China depends on 40%. Japan
75%.
Prime Minister Takiichi of Japan has
said that listen if the circle closes we
run out of oil in about 8 n months. The
entire Japanese economy would collapse
in 8 9 months. If the circle moves were
to close and guess what the Iranians
have closed the circle moves okay so we
can expect that the entire global
economy will suffer greatly over the
next few months. All right. So that's
point number one. Point number two is
okay so the GC sends oil across the shoo
and what do they get back in return?
Food guys.
All right so
people don't appreciate the GCC but it
is really the lynch pin of the American
empire because what is the American
empire? The American empire is the petro
dollar. All right. The idea of the petro
dollar is this. The US dollar is worth
nothing. It's only valued when people
want it. But the GC says that if you
want oil from us, you have to pay us in
US dollars. Okay? Then that is the basis
of the value of the US dollar.
So if the GCC collapses, the American
economy and American empire both
collapse at the same time.
The problem though is the GCC is an
artificial construct of empire. It does
not exist naturally. Why? Because that's
no food. That's no oil, no water. Okay
guys, no food, no water. So these cities
are able to grow in the millions because
of all these petrol dollars flowing in.
If you close off the moose, there's no
food coming in, right? They're all going
to starve.
How much food does the GCD get from
overseas? 80%.
80% of all the food it consumes comes
from overseas that it imports. It does
not grow by itself. It imports.
All right.
So the sugar moose is really key and
again the Iranians will close it in
order to strangle the global economy and
therefore bankrupt the American empire.
All right. Second thing you will notice
is these mountains.
These mountains is what we call Iran.
All right, this is Iran.
This is GCC.
Okay, this is not a fair matchup, right?
Because these are mountains. And what
can you do in mountains? We can hide
rocket bases. You can hide drone bases.
You can hide missiles. And that's the
entire Iranian offensive strategy. All
right. From here they can hide missiles
and drones from which to attack the GCC.
And what are they attacking? They're
attacking
um
three things, right? They're attacking
American military bases.
American
military bases.
That's number one.
Okay. Is it possible for the Durkens to
defend against these hacks? The answer
is no. THEY'RE NOT. IT'S NOT. IT'S THE
SILLIEST THING IN the world. You have
all these bases in the Middle East, but
you cannot defend them against the
Iranians. That's kind of strange. Okay,
that's number one. Number two is
oil and energy.
How hard is it to blow up an oil field
with a drone? Not hard at all. Can you
defend these oil fields? No, you cannot.
All right. Number three, and that's most
important, is water.
Okay, you guys don't know this, but the
GCC
has little access to fresh water. So the
only way that it can produce water is
what is what we call dalination plants.
Okay, these factories that take salt
water and then through electrical
chemical process turn it into fresh
water for the population to use. 60%
of the water supply and as you see comes
from the alination plants. Okay, 60%.
Is it hard to blow up the dalination
plant using a drone? The answer is it's
very easy. You understand? Okay, so you
have this absurd situation where Iran is
a mountain fortress where it can hide
its offensive capacity
and the GCC it's just this desert, this
flat desert and it is exposed to attack
and there's nothing it can do about it.
Okay.
So, at any point in this war, the
Iranians can choose to just destroy the
entire GCC and there's nothing that
anyone can do about it.
Okay? But Iran also has a weakness.
Okay? And this is fundamental. So, Iran
also has a water problem. Okay? So, for
the longest time, they suffer a drought
issue.
Okay? this climate change.
And so what the plan of the Israelis
Americans is is destroy the water supply
of the Iranians because the fortress it
it is a mountain fortress but it can
also be a mountain prison as well where
people are trapped inside with no access
to water. Okay. So what we're going to
see right now, we're we're already
seeing attacks on civilian
infrastructure, hospitals. In the
future, you will see attacks on water
supply, on dams, on reservoirs,
on power plants. The point, the idea is
to make Iran so inhabitable that the
people will will have to rebel against
the people or there'll be a refugee
crisis in Iran. Okay. So as you can see
from this map, this war it is the end of
the world. Okay, both sides have the
potential to destroy each other. It's
really a question of how far do they
want to go, right? We we can also say
this is almost a game of chicken.
Okay,
we can blow we can blow each other up.
How far do you want to go?
And the problem is this. The problem is
that the Iranians are Shia
which believes in martyrdom and you've
killed the religious leader that K. So
they're willing to go very very far. The
GC the GC countries are Muslim but
they're materialistic. They love money.
And also most of the population are
expatriots, foreigners. 90% of Dubai are
foreigners. Guess guess what's going to
happen if they suffer? They're going to
run away. Okay, so this is not a fair
matchup.
The big question that people have is
first of all,
are the Americans going to use ground
troops?
Because the only way that you can defeat
Iran is by using ground troops. Okay,
that's a big question we will look at
over the next few weeks. Will will
America send his army half a million 2
million soldiers to topple the
government? Okay, that's question number
one. Question number two, nuclear
weapons.
If you're losing a war,
would you choose to use nuclear weapons?
Okay, that's another big question that
we have. Okay, another big question that
we have is who gets involved? Because
this situation is so dire that Europe,
okay, specifically Germany,
France and Britain
are talking about entering this war. And
guess what? If that happens, it is
possible that Russia and China
will also enter this war on the side of
the Iranians. This is World War II,
okay?
because of the importance of the
political moves, because of the
importance of the Middle East, everyone
has to get involved at some point.
And we're going to use game theory to
really try to understand what what's
happening on the ground and where this
could lead us. Okay.
All right. You guys understand? All
right. All right. Let's continue. Okay.
So again, there are American bases all
over the Middle East
and originally these bases were
established to protect them from
basically their own people. Okay, these
are monarchies that were imposed on
these nations by the Anglo-American
Empire, the British first and then the
Americans came to support these
monarchies.
And so they provide defense.
But then you're like, wait a minute
here. I mean, didn't we just say that
these American bases can actually defend
these people that they're exposed? And
the and the reason and the answer is
yes, that's true. But remember that the
American military was built during the
Cold War. Okay? And the Cold War was a
war between the Soviet Union and um
America. And so the cold war was defined
with something called MAD, mutually
assured destruction, because both had
nuclear weapons. Okay? So they didn't
really go to war against each other. And
so in other words, these bases aren't
really meant to defend
uh these nations from other enemies.
They're really meant to impose American
authority in the Middle East. Okay? And
it's the idea of this. It's the idea
that empire
it is really a
image. It is a hallucination. It's an
idea. Empire is the it's an aura of
invisibility and inability. Okay? If you
fear it, then you obey it.
But it's not really designed to fight a
war. Okay? And and so that's why we have
this absurd situation.
And because there are so many bases in
the GCC, that gives the Iranians the
perfect pretext to attack them in order
destroy the GCC economy, which will
destroy the American empire. Right? All
right. So this is how the war shipping
out. Okay. So So the red is the Israelis
and the Americans. The yellow are the
Iranians. And as you can see, the
Iranians are attacking everywhere,
primarily
Israel, okay? But also, as you can see,
a lot of focus on Bahrain and Qatar. And
again, the intention is to destabilize
the economy and the government, okay?
It's it's to try to get as much
instability as possible,
right?
Okay. And as you can see, the Americans
and the Israelis are focused on Tran.
And so the Americans is use some
something we call shock and all.
And the very idea of shock and all is
you decapitate
the enemy. You cut off the head, the
body will fall down. Okay. The problem
though is again the Iranians see this as
a religious war and so the Iranians have
of have announced total war.
Okay. And so what this means is that
right now command and control in in Iraq
is decentralized.
There's no one person telling everyone
what to do. Every region has its own
orders, has its own strategy. And so if
you knock out Tran, everyone else keeps
on going. So you knock off the take off
the head, it doesn't change anything.
Okay? But unfortunately
the um Israelis and Americans use this
as a military doctrine. Military
doctrine just means how to how you
design your military for what purpose.
And so the even though the Americans
seem like an invincible army, they are
not equipped to fight a 21st century war
against drones, against
religious fanatics. Okay? They're just
not
all right. But unfortunately, because of
military doctrine, they're going to keep
on attacking Tran. Now the great irony
of all this is that the Iranians who
will be most supportive of you of regime
change are actually in the cities
because they are educated they're
progressive the people who are most
fundamentally against you will fight you
to the death are religious fanatics the
Shia militants living in the rural areas
okay so this is a really silly thing
where you are actually destroying those
who who will most likely support you And
you're leaving alone those who are most
likely to commit jihad against you. All
right.
Any questions so far guys? Are you
clear? All right. So another idea that I
want you guys to understand is idea of
asymmetry.
Asymmetry.
All right. So what is asymmetry?
Asymmetry means that the two sides are
choosing to fight different wars using
different techniques because
one is much stronger than the other.
Okay, America has a great empire. It has
unlimited resources. It has a USD. It
has it controls the world, right? Iran
uh is a country that has been under
economic sanctions for the past 45
years. It's poor. It's technology is
very limited. Okay. But as we learn in
this class, actually those nations that
are poor actually have more energy.
They're more open and they're more
cohesive. Right? So let me give an
example. This is what we call the Shahad
drones. Shahad drones. Each of these
drones cost $50,000 at most. Okay? At
most. It can go as cheap as $35,000 US.
But one of them is one of them is
$50,000. As you can see, you can fit a
lot of these drones to a truck that can
go anywhere in Iran and they can hide
anywhere. All right, so the thing to
understand is first of all, these drones
are cheap. They're easy and they're easy
to make. They make about 500 a day.
Okay? And estimates are about there's
80,000
um right now that the Iranians have. So
they can go on for a long long time.
Okay? And one of these drones again can
knock out a dissalination plant. It can
knock out a oil field. It can knock out
a hotel. It can do a lot of damage.
Okay. And it's easily
transportable. You can hide it anywhere.
You can you can use it from anywhere.
Okay? And that's what the Iranians are
using as an offensive weapon. And how do
Americans defend against this? They use
something called a fad. Right.
Right guys, this is what they use. FAD.
FAD stands for thermal high altitude air
defense. And they also have like Patriot
systems. There's a lot. Okay. The thing
that you will that you need to know know
about the system is it's really
expensive. This missile guys cost $1
million.
$1 million.
So, there's this $50,000 drone coming
your way and you throw a million dollar
missile at it. Okay? And often these
missiles miss, so you have to throw two
or three missiles at it. Okay? So, you
you're spending two to $3 million on
each $50,000 that the spend.
That's kind of silly. Second thing
you'll notice is that this thing is
really big and really slow and therefore
you can't really move it around.
Therefore, it's pretty easy for the
Iranians to spot where this is and
attack it. And when these planes blow
up, that's a lot of money, guys. Okay?
Then you're like, "What? But this makes
no sense. You know, the Iranians have
drones. They've had drones for like 10
years. You've also seen drones used in
the Russia Ukraine war to devastating
effect. Why don't the Americans know
this? Why did they prepare? Okay. And
again, it has to do with military
military doctrine because military
doctrine determines how you fight a war.
It determines on your bureaucracy and it
and it determines how you spend your
resources. Okay? And unfortunately, the
Americans are used to fighting something
called the cold war,
right? And the cold war you can actually
fight the war. You can actually use uh
kill each other because then you people
use nuclear weapons. The cold war was
about flexing.
Flexing. Okay, you see how big and
powerful I am?
Okay, that's all it was.
These weapon systems are designed to
scare the crap out of you. They are
designed to impress you and as a result,
they cost a lot of money. They don't do
anything. All right, so that's the
entire American military. It costs a lot
and it doesn't really do anything and
it's not resilient. It's not innovative.
It's not open. All right. Also, the
other thing I have to say this, okay, is
if you look at the American military,
it's corrupt.
So, this is really about corruption.
So, the Americans don't really care
about winning a war. What they care
about is spending as much money as
possible because then they get a cut. It
doesn't make sense, right? And that's
why the Americans are in situation as
they are. All right, let's continue.
All right, so um something that people
don't really talk about, but you need to
understand it's the water issue in the
GCC in the Middle East in Iraq. All
right. So, um
this is a map of the world and if you
are like blue, Brazil, Canada, you have
nothing to worry about because you have
a lot of water, a lot of fresh water,
very little population.
All right? So, um 100%
just means 100% water stress just means
that you drink as much water as the
environment produces.
Okay. So, you want to be below 100%. To
be sustainable. Ideally, you you you
want to be at 10%. Okay.
If it goes above 100%, it means that you
are drinking more water, using more
water than the environment actually
produces. Okay? So, you're putting
stress on the environment.
So, 200%
is really bad, right? Because you're
you're using twice as much water as
environment produces.
Guess what, guys? Look at the Middle
East. Okay, Egypt,
6,420%.
Saudi Arabia,
883%.
All right. Ban almost 4,000%.
Dubai 17,000%.
All right,
these. So water is a huge issue. Again,
it doesn't matter if Iran
kills American soldiers, destroys
American military. It doesn't have to do
that. All it has to do is destroy the
dissalination plants and then the GCC is
destroyed. Okay.
But it's also true that Iran
has water issues. 72% is pretty bad.
Okay. So even though the Iranians could
destroy the GCC much faster
than the Americans could destroy Iran,
Iran is still in trouble. Okay. So so so
let let me give you an example of this.
This is like so sorry. So this is
another map that shows you uh the issue
of water scarcity. Okay. And it's just
basically the Middle East. Okay. Their
biggest issue in the future is water.
Okay. And that's where the geopolitical
tensions will rise in the future over
water. India is also affected as well.
Okay. All right.
All right. So, let's look at the map,
guys. This is called Lake Heria in
northern Iran. It's the sixth largest
saltwater lake in the world or it used
to be. Okay. This is what it was in
1984. Th This is a shallow. This is a
deep. Okay? You guys see that? It's
really big, right? 20 years later, guys.
This is what it looks like.
There's no more water here. You can walk
from here over to there. Okay, there's
some water over here, but it's shallow
now. That's how serious the water issue
is in Iran. And that's the weak point
that the Americans and the Israelis will
attack. All right. They want to make
sure that Iran has no access to fresh
water which will cause devastation in
their nation. Okay, that's strategy
number one. Strategy number two is this.
This is a map of
the different ethnic minorities
in Iran. As you can see, it's a very
diverse place. In the center are the
Persians, but you also have
10 other groups as well. And in the
borderlands, it's basically a different
country, right? Like these are basically
different countries.
And so these places have more common
common areas with their neighbors than
they do with Iran. Okay. So the second
weakness of Iran, the first is the
water. The second is the ethnic makeup
of the country. So the strategy of the
Americans and the Israelis moving
forward is destroy Iran as a coherent
nation state divided into ethnic
archives and have them fight over water.
That is the grand plan of the Israelis
and the Americans. Okay.
All right. This is this is this is the
vision where Persia is limited and then
all these other places are sponsored by
the Americans and the Israelis. They're
given money. They're given weapons.
They're given political support. And
then this war will wage over water
forever. Okay? And this is how you
destroy Iran and make sure Iran is no
longer a viable threat to you. That is
the plan of the Americans. Okay? As as
you can see, it's pretty evil plan. And
that's why they have not announced it,
right? Because if you announce it,
you're like, why are you doing this?
What the Persians, what did the ever do
to you to warrant you coming destroying
their civilization? And the answer is
nothing. Right? So the Americans will
never admit they're doing this. But if
you look at the map of war supply of
ethnic
um tensions, this is the optimal game
game theory strategy for them to use
against Iran. Okay, does that make
sense? This is a long-term plan that
they have in place and it's all moving
towards this plan. But now the question
then is how can the Iranians respond to
this? And the answer is this. This is a
map of the Muslim world. Okay. So the
um light green are the Sunni people.
Okay. That's 90% of the entire Muslim
population about two two billion people.
Okay. Then you have in dark green the
Shia.
So as you can see the main place of the
Shia is Iran. Okay, Iran is one of the
few Shia nations in the world. But you
can also see from this map that Shia are
spread throughout the world. Okay. And
so the first thing that the Iranians
want to do is create a jihad to unite
all the Shia against American Empire.
All right. So what they want to do is
create a uprising
and it's already happening guys. Um the
Shia in Pakistan stormed the American
embassy in Pakistan and the Americans
killed a lot of people. Okay. the Shia
have have attacked the American embassy
in uh Iraq.
The American embassy
uh are being attacked in a lot of
places. Right? So the first strategy is
to create a international global jihad
of the Shia against the American empire
and it's already happening. it will
continue for a long long term long time
because the Americans have killed the um
Kame okay and that requires vengeance.
The other thing though is that
it can unify
the Muslim world. Okay, if you look at
this map, most of the Muslim world is
actually run by dictatorships that are
not popular at all. Okay. And they're
allowed to exist because they're like an
empire, right? You go to Saudi Arabia,
Egypt, uh Algeria,
uh
these places, they're all run by clients
of American Empire, right? So if you
rally the people who hate their
governments and you overthrow them, then
that makes Iran
the leader of the the Islamic world. Not
just the Shia world, but the Islamic
world. This creates something called tax
Islam.
That is the end goal, guys. Okay? If you
do that, then you don't have to worry
about the Americans and the Israelis
anymore. Right? So the Israeli game
plan, the American game plan is to
fracture Iran into ethnic enclaves and
they'll fight over water for the rest of
their lives and they all die. The
Iranian game plan is to create a
religious war, a crusade that unifies
the Shia people that overthrows the
American Empire and establish something
called the Pax Islamaka.
All right.
So again,
the key is the GCC.
All right. So the game plan is this. You
have to destroy the GCC. Why? Because
the GCC is the lynch pin of the American
Empire.
So what the GC does is it sells oil.
sells oil and then for US dollars.
Where does it put US dollars? It puts US
dollars into the American stock market.
All right. So this this is investments
of the UAE, okay? Saudi Arabia and
Kuwait into
the US financial markets. As you can see
from 2012
up to today, it's been exploding.
All right? Because the US financial
markets is one of the safest places
where you can put your money. The
intention is this. The intention is,
hey, if I cut off oil
and these countries no longer have
access to US dollars, they're forced to
spend whatever resources they have on
protecting themselves. Okay? And then
guess what happens? The stock market
collapses. The summer collapses. The
stock market is the real growth engine
of the US economy. the entire US economy
collapses with it. All right, there are
about maybe seven companies in uh
America that accounts for about a
quarter of stock market growth. Okay,
these seven countries, these seven uh
companies of course are are AI
companies. Nvidia,
um
um Microsoft, Google, Apple. Okay, these
are the companies when and then these
companies are heavily invested in by the
GCC nations. So if these nations are
long long no longer able to invest in
the stock market, these companies will
collapse in value and with that that
would lead to economic depression in
America.
It doesn't make sense. All right, so
that is the situation for today. Today
was just an overview, guys. Okay, I know
we covered a lot. I know there's a lot
to take in, but over the next few weeks,
we will explore each issue
um in depth and really understand what's
really going on. Okay? All right. So,
any questions, guys?
Any questions about what we've just
learned?
Okay.
Um if other countries such as Italy,
France, China or Russia they have
also joined this war like what's the
cause of they join the war because of
oil or those resources.
Okay,
that's a great question. Okay, so I
don't want to spend too much time on
this question because we will explore
this question as we move along. Okay. So
the question is what brings the world
into this conflict and the easy answer
is
um just oil access energy access okay
they need to protect their energy
supplies because remember uh it's a very
complicated situation because Europe is
now fighting Russia. So so Europe is not
buying any oil resources energy
resources from Russia. Therefore it
depends a lot on the on the GCC. So the
GC is not providing them energy then the
Europe will go bankrupt. Okay. So Europe
needs to enter this war on behalf of
Americans.
Okay. And then you Russia which cannot
allow Iran to fall because if Iran falls
then they'll come after Russia next.
Right? China is actually neutral.
China's okay with either scenario. But
that's just the way that the Chinese
system is set up. Okay. So we're going
to explore this question as we move
along. But it's a very complicated
issue. All right. Okay. And each nation
will have its own different strategic
interests to consider.
Right. And what we need to know what
what we need to figure out is that this
war in the Middle East is actually
connected to to the Ukraine war. And as
we move along, I'll show you how these
two two things connect together. Okay.
Any other questions, guys?
Okay, great. So um we'll continue this
discussion on Thursday.